Speaker 1: All right, it that I am really,
really frustrated with what I'm about to tell
you, we have been banned from Facebook's video
monetization for 90 days, 90 days because
of anti-vax content.
Now I know all of you are probably saying
David anti-vax, what on earth are you talking
about?
You have been following the science on vaccines
and explaining the effectiveness of these
vaccines and the I know, I know, believe me,
but we have been banned from Facebook's monetization
for 90 days.
And I'm going to explain to you why in a second.
Now the back story here, of course, is we
know that at the flip of a switch, we can
lose entire sources of revenue for our program.
How do we know that?
Because it's happened?
Ad Apocalypse took place in April of 2017,
when as a result of an ad playing on a racist
YouTube video that had nothing to do with
us, YouTube and advertisers essentially switched
off advertising on news and politics content.
For close to two months, we lost ninety nine
point ninety eight percent of our YouTube
revenue for nearly two months.
And that made us realize we've got to diversify.
We've got to diversify.
That's why we started streaming on Twitch.
That's why we started posting all of our content
to Facebook instead of just a clip or two
a day.
Now, about a year ago, we lost monetization
for seven days from Facebook, and we never
found out why we were told you violated community
guidelines.
Will which which post couldn't find out.
What did we say?
Couldn't find out, but it was only seven days,
so we just decided to wait it out.
But we were told if this happens again and
it's like, if what happens again, if this
happens again, you will lose monetization
for 90 days now because we have decided to
diversify revenue sources because of what's
happened in the past.
Facebook has grown to be close to 20 percent
of our revenue, and we have now lost that
20 percent for three months.
What is the post that caused this?
I will show it to you.
We covered early last week the conflict between
Alex Jones and Donald Trump.
Donald Trump now has been advocating more,
more more publicly for the vaccine.
Alex Jones is anti-vaccine and turned on Donald
Trump.
So we posted, Is this where Trump's base is
going to draw the line?
And we linked to our video.
Alex Jones loses it on Trump.
Jones against vaccine Trump Pro.
This is creating a rift, and of course, the
things Alex Jones said in the video.
Gene therapies killing people.
We said all of these things are lies that
got us banned from Facebook monetization for
90 days, 90 days.
This is close to 20 percent of our revenue
now.
And of course, it is a complete and total
misunderstanding.
We aren't anti-vax.
Now I know there are people who are going
to hear this.
I already I'm imagining the comments on on
YouTube.
David, this is your just deserts.
This is what you deserve, David, because you've
been cheering for people being canceled from
Facebook or YouTube or whatever.
No, no, no, no, no.
I hope that some of you are sophisticated
enough to understand what is going on here
versus what we've talked about in the past.
I am 100 percent respectful of the fact that
Facebook, YouTube, Twitter, whoever can establish
their terms and conditions for what is allowed
on the platform.
Facebook is completely right to say we're
not going to allow the spread of COVID disinformation.
They still allow it, but they are completely
right to say that will be our policy.
The problem here isn't that it's that it's
not being applied correctly.
We are obviously not an anti-vaccine show.
So all the people, oh, but David, you said,
you know they're coming for you now.
This is what you deserve.
No, no, no, no.
They're not coming for me, for anything we
actually did.
I respect that Facebook can have it, enforce
terms and conditions.
We just didn't violate them.
This is a mistake, and there's no recourse
to get it reversed.
There's no way to get a hold of anyone at
Facebook.
So if you actually work or have someone you
know that works at Facebook, that could help
with this, please email info at David Pakman
dot com.
Don't.
Send me a link to a forum where I can submit.
We've done that, Facebook doesn't respond
to any of that stuff.
OK, I've reached out to every.
I asked Jank younger, Hey, do you have a contact?
I asked our YouTube rep.
It's like, why?
I'm like, Listen, I know you work for Google,
not Facebook.
But do you happen to know anyone at Facebook
if you actually work there or know someone
who might be able to help?
But there is every indication that for three
months we are losing 20 percent of our revenue,
and I know some of you will say, Screw Facebook,
we don't need it if we don't work to have
our content there.
We are giving more space to the actual right
wing disinformation that spreads uncontrolled
on Facebook.
So I know it's easy to say just get off the
platform.
The platform is huge and we are on there to
try to fight the trash that is spread like
wildfire on Facebook.
So all I can ask you is help us make up for
that 20 percent.
We're going to lose for three months.
Grab a membership on my website.
That's really the one ask.
I have 20 percent for three months.
That's a big chunk.
You know, we've got a number of employees
now and a lot of different things that we're
doing and 20 percent is a big deal.
We've created a coupon code.
It's kind of a joke.
It's Facebook with two f's, you know, EFF
Facebook.
OK, yeah, that's it's a joke, OK?
But you can go to join Packman dot com.
Use the code EFF Facebook.
You'll get a discount and hopefully we can
make up a little bit of this.
Lost 20 percent, but an absolutely devastating
thing.
Devastating thing, and I'll keep people posted
about it